you
can I send you push notifications can I
send you push notifications do I have to
be here
that's alright alright
so that was a poor start but let's try
again hi everyone my name's Don - I'm a
developer evangelist for Twilio if you
don't know about 2000 come see us we've
been hanging out in the sponsor area all
the time and we'd love to chat what I'm
here to talk to you about today is
progressive web apps we've actually not
heard a lot I think about progressive
web apps this time around a gyroscope I
think that means it's an interesting
part in the in the lifes life cycle of a
new feature of a new way that we build
applications and then I think we're just
kind of working on them and we're not
quite sure what we're talking about
anymore which is fine but what I'm I
like is the is the technology behind it
what we can do with it and the
serviceworker is my favorite thing
because we have JavaScript that runs
outside of our page now and I love that
and what I really love about it is that
it's now supported in every major
browser thank you everyone thank you
browsers I've done it and so this means
we can really really start talking to
our businesses and our places of work to
build applications that are better for
users can build more interesting stuff
can build more native app like features
because that's the kind of some of the
things that we've been missing that the
native applications have had over us and
one of those is push notifications
I think push notifications are wonderful
and that's why I want to talk to you
about them today because I'm not sure
you do so push notification support is
probably important to cover because it's
not quite everyone because come on
Safari we can get there and we can do it
you know how to do push notifications
you've had a native app for anyway we'll
get there
and I just wanted to show a quick
example because I am so delighted that
it did appear in this is edge it works
in edge out of the box with the first
version of of serviceworkers push
notifications came in and it goes away
and then
and I had to redownload a VM flat
because you know because we go to can I
use it does look a little bit more red a
little bit more dangerous but I don't
think that's the important thing if
you're looking at the Reds and the
greens on this it's not correct correct
you wanna be looking up in the top-right
corner there where it says almost 75% of
active like users based on the global
stats that can I use users almost 75% of
people have access to these so we need
to be thinking about them building them
and building them the correct way push
notifications are good and that's what I
want to talk to you about today we're
gonna cover kind of three things very
briefly I put on how to push then we're
going to talk about good push
notifications and then we're going to
talk about permissions and permissions
get skulls because we're doing it wrong
so quickly on how to push if there's
quite a convoluted set up to make
personifications actually work so you
start with a user in a browser
and you have to register your
serviceworker and once you do that you
can then ask for permission to send push
notifications to the user when they say
if they say yes you'll get back a URL
and a couple of encryption keys which
you'll want to save on your server
somewhere so you can use them later then
later when you want to make a push
notification from your server you send a
post request to that URL that you got
which is the browser's notification
service you can encrypt some data with
that using those keys you got earlier so
that the browser's can't read what
you're sending to your users that's cool
and then the service will send a push to
your to your device which will wake up
the service worker which will react if
you are listening to the push event and
eventually send that back to the browser
and make the notification happen I'm not
going to go into the technical side of
that that the code or anything because
you're all smart people and you can read
documentation so if you want to find out
about that mdn and the Google developer
Doc's are both very good at telling you
how all this works because I don't think
how to do this is the problem we can
write code and we can write code that
works we need to talk about actually
doing this well actually doing good push
notifications you see this is a tweet
that comes across every once in a while
on Twitter I like deer every website I
never want post notifications and that's
not true
I don't think that's true I don't
believe in I know I want personification
for something there are useful things
for this for push notifications are
incredibly useful for the right things I
do believe that the person that says
that maybe doesn't want push
notifications it's entirely possible
that you are a person when you get your
phone the first thing you do is go to
settings and turn off notifications and
never get that and that's fine but it's
not true for everyone I have some
examples of some good notifications
because I think we need to hear them and
maybe we're not thinking about that
quite so well appoint your reminders is
a really good one so as I said I work at
to a Leo and we've been sending we have
an API for sending text messages which
we've had around for about eight years
now and text messages get used for
notification purposes as well and one of
our one of our clients the Arkansas
Children's Hospital used appoint
reminders and they cut down no-shows
bearing in mind this is a Children's
Hospital appointments for Sick Children
no-shows were 20% and after they
implemented notifications to say hey
you've got an appointment tomorrow it
dropped a 2% like that's real life
really important stuff keeping doctors
doing the job that they should be doing
and getting kids to appointments that
they need to be going to chat alerts is
an obvious one I'm sure we don't like to
ignore them some of the time because
they're not normally the Goodin they're
not always good news but then you know
that having been in Berlin for the last
week and kind of try to hang out
meet up with different people that push
notifications to various methods of
chatting and messaging people have kept
me on the ball for that ETA less things
arriving if you order a car food any
kind of delivery at all getting a
notification that it's there is
excellent
it means you actually leave your house
and go get in the car or you go pick up
that food and then event updates
especially things like conferences if we
wanted to be sending stuff to you you
don't to download an entire native
application for a one or two day event
the browser can help us in this one and
certainly other events like flights also
on my mind having flown over here and
three different planes to get here being
told and updated when when I could check
in and also when there were delays make
that so much easier these notifications
will have kind of three tenets to them
that you should consider when building
with push notifications and that they
are timely actionable and personal
timely is sort of obvious like if I get
a push notification to say that my car
has just arrived after I finished the
journey that's not very useful but
there's other considerations as well
this is a picture that goes around
Twitter once in a while as well it's the
this slack decision tree of whether to
send somebody a push notification and a
whole bunch of you don't need to read it
but a whole bunch of those things are
you know timings based stuff all the
pages of the person asleep of the mess
I'm working do they really need this
weirdly enough when I'm using slack I
can be on the desktop typing a message
to somebody and my phone will buzz with
a notification so I modified this to I
think that's how it works for me I don't
know what's gone on there but this other
concept right there's considerations
like the time of day the time zone and
then the number of notifications you're
sending somebody as well you don't to
just keep piling them on because that's
not helpful after a while let me get
some actionable stuff and this is
actionable notifications where you you
get something that you can do something
about
if you receive a chat message from
someone then you want to read it respond
to it deal with that if your car is here
it is time to leave the house or it's
time to get on the street and look for
it if your flight is open for check-in
you might get the extra leg room seats
if you go check in now important to me
and then their personal there's one
thing you might have noticed about all
of those is that they're all about you
I'm sure I'm pretty sure if you searched
Twitter two weeks ago for push
notifications they're a bunch of people
very surprised that they had 20 or so
notifications that some guy was getting
married as the Royal Wedding goes off
and news organizations like we must push
this to everyone
it's not personal that's not actionable
it's not interesting it's all that's not
true some people probably wanted that
but I didn't say so you do have to you
can break the rules on this though as I
said some people might have wanted royal
wedding notifications a really good
example of this was back in 2016 when
the Guardian team in the UK covered the
UK general election and this Divis will
experiment with push notifications that
kept people up to date with how the
votes were coming in overnight this is
amazing bit of work as well because they
actually assembled this image in the
serviceworker and if you work with the
serviceworker you know that there's no
canvas element there's no way to really
manipulate images properly so they were
doing it entirely with buffers which is
kind of amazing but this actually shows
one other thing in the middle between
latest declared in settings there's a
button to stop
that's one they programmed in because
maybe you do want to go to bed because
this goes all night and you don't want
to keep hitting notifications and so you
have to let let people opt-out from
within your application this is the
Twitter iOS application where you can
choose which push notifications you get
now they have a bad reputation of adding
things to this and checking them so you
have to keep revisiting once in a while
but
if I want the ends and I want @mentions
but I don't want Twitter news because
then you can go sort it out inside the
application because the alternative for
us on the web is terrible
the alternative looks a little like this
I'm just going to go out to Chrome for a
second here
make sure notifications are working yep
so we're just registering for push
notifications there and then when I send
one it will come into the screen it'll
come into the screen it's not going to
do it okay cool
so in the notification you get to see as
you hover over it there are two buttons
one importantly is settings and when you
click that Settings button you get taken
to this screen this screen allows you to
block that individual websites and even
worse allows you to block all of them
if one website sends a bad person
notification they can't user cannot opt
out of it's a very quick step to that
user blocking every single applications
push notifications this is what it looks
like in Firefox as well it's not good
I am terrified that the rest of the
Internet can affect my application in
that way if I am sending useful things
to a user that they want to receive but
they get put off by an abuse of this API
then that's that's horrifying so this
leads me onto the other terrifying part
of this which is the permissions
I found one of those tweets that that
kind of said dear every website I don't
want you to post notifications to my
desktop I don't want to subscribe to
your thing very pop-up I don't want you
to know my location
please stop also playing that video I'm
angry and sad now websites are making
users angry and sad because they are
doing this the power of the web has been
increasing over the recent years as we
get permission as we get the ability to
use methods and and and device
capabilities like geolocation like the
push notifications like media devices
camera and microphone Bluetooth MIDI web
USB all of those things but we require
permission for them because they're more
invasive and that's correct and the web
asourian's had this like permission the
the permissions model that you asked for
it when you need it
which is good except we keep asking we
keep doing lots of things it doesn't
make you ask it when you need it I want
to pick on a couple of sites apologies
to them but they shouldn't have done
this this is what happens when you load
producthunt calm for the first time it
looks like an interesting site what all
right there when you get that for the
first time why are we being asked
permission for push notifications what
is what is that about and they're not
the only ones this is seen at you know a
tech and review sites push notifications
first time assess site point calm not
overly push notification permissions but
an entire page overlay asking you to pay
for stuff you don't even know what the
site does yet it's supposed to look like
that and this is a site that does
tutorials on web development
and then YouTube did it to me the other
day this is not the first time I visited
YouTube but this is the home page and it
gave me no context about what it wanted
to do with these push notifications it
just asked for permission context is
absolutely king in this case absolutely
King because why would you give
permission to any sites to have one of
those invasive permissions and this
counts of a geolocation and this counts
for media devices as well why would you
give permission to one of those sites
without context and then in recent
changes from chroma they stopped
allowing you to just dismiss the
notification the permission you either
block or allow and so that's straight
into block straightaway obviously we
need to stop this we need to stop this
or our users will stop it for us there
are sites like how-to geek who are now
publishing posts on how to turn these
off in every browser how to avoid these
push notifications at all and again this
is one or two sites that can ruin it for
the rest of us and ruin it for the users
as well and Firefox
if you're here which I hope you are
let's have a chat about this because I
don't think this is cool
I don't think building a feature and
then telling people that the feature you
built into your browser is terrible is a
good idea especially when I think we can
agree that some of those personification
examples I gave earlier are good ideas
and can help people so maybe now you can
think of some good reasons to get push
notifications Firefox let's sort this
out so please if you have built push
notifications into a into your website
at all do not demand notification
permissions on page load don't
my worry as I said already is that
permissions or permissions have become
the new pop ups they are they will be
reviled and dismissed by users that just
be annoyances in the browser and it
doesn't matter what the feature behind
them is well there is push notifications
to you location whatever they just
they'll just dismiss it they don't care
and when users dismiss those permissions
by default our web platform loses its
power to build engaging and useful
experiences for those users that little
check box is terrifying so please don't
and notification permissions on page
later are suggestions though it's like
because I don't think I can reach
everybody by standing on stage I'm very
glad to be able to reach you and tell
you this but we have to do better than
that I had some suggestions for now and
then for the future for how we can
improve this in general for now is just
better patterns of UX for this just wait
build up the context that require that
we'll make these are aware of why you
need that permission a map gone from the
chrome dev rel team wrote a great post
and a great example application based on
this he built a fake airline ticketing
site and once you finish the purchase
process of an airline ticket at the
bottom of the screen it pops up get
notifications for flight delays and
you've just bought of airline ticket and
you've no wish to turn up to the airport
10 hours early because your flights
delayed this seems like a good idea I'll
click it oh there's the permissions pop
up I know exactly what I'm going to get
out of this it can be obvious still
don't put the permissions up but if you
are building a chat application like
slack that kind of top bar across the
top is reasonable
there are same for geolocation
permissions if there's a map on the back
of this on the screen behind the
notification it's probably obvious what
we're trying to do here so that's fine
but for the future this I think is more
important because I think together we
can work to fix this in general this
needs to be the start of a conversation
or the continuing of a conversation that
has existed my suggestion was the
browser should enforce it user
interaction before asking for a
permission
something like like pop-ups where you
have to be you have to have had a click
before you can pop something up there's
arguments about this but you can get
involved in them on the github on the wi
cg repos there is an interventions repo
which is great but issue 49 is the
suggestion from somebody else that there
should be a user interaction before a
permissions pop up that conversation is
stalled right now and the reason behind
it is because there are a couple of
companies that have built up a service
that does push notifications on behalf
of other websites for those websites
that haven't managed to change on to
HTTPS yet which you need for the
serviceworker I think those businesses
are tenuous at best it's a transitional
thing and the web is going to HTTP all
the way through so whilst I'm
sympathetic with the fact that they're
trying to build a business I'm not sure
it's a great foundation to be doing so
on but maybe a user interaction is not
the best suggestion we need to get
involved and come up with better ones
there's also the permissions API they
emerge it's an emerging spec from the
w3c and currently the permissions API
just kind of collects in one place where
you can find out if you can if you have
asked for Mauritian and what there is
what the response was but I feel like
that could be in that could be better as
well perhaps we could have an API that
let us ask whether we can ask permission
yet perhaps the browser should be
implementing some kind of
eristic a little likely at the home
screen pop up we're only in infer for a
progressive web app you can only add to
homescreen after a certain amount of
engagement but within Li we need this to
be deterministic as well so being able
to ask the permissions API whether I
have enough engagement yet might be a
good idea but again I need more ideas
need more input for this and we need to
start talking about it more so in
conclusion I think push notifications
are awesome for the right things not for
breaking news but for important timely
actionable and personal actions one more
time for this one
do not ever demand permissions for
anything on a page load make those
notifications timely actionable and
personal or don't break the rules but
allow those use of to opt-out inside
your application so they don't turn it
off for everyone because of for use of
what's first notifications like that the
whole web suffers they suffer because
they can't get the good push
notifications that we're talking about
and they will block it if they have a
bad experience but we has good web
developers who are coming to a
conference like this who are hanging out
in a great community like this we can
provide good experiences for both these
permissions and for notifications in
general we might have to work together
to find out how we can do this better
well that's what I want to see and I
want us to see us building progressive
web apps that improve experiences for
users that improve the web in general
and not aggressive web apps which just
get up in everybody's face and make
users sad and angry we can go and do
that that is why I brought a few thank
you so much
[Applause]